um what's it like uh for you cuz
obviously you know to me New York is
kind of there's so much going on at once
right now obviously the drill shit's
super hot um shout out to Connie Diamond
she was up here yourself you're popping
you're doing your thing there so many
female MC's doing their thing Jen Carter
from 41's really dope um for you like
it's got to be exciting to kind of be a
part of this like new Resurgence this
new energy coming out of New York for
sure I'm like I'm just happy to be a
part of the team part of the ride you
know what I'm saying it's like everybody
doing their thing I hope you know we
could continue to be impactful grow
together yeah everybody's so super
talented I respect all of them it's just
like it's just so cool cuz you know you
go from watching everything happening to
like blinking and out everybody my Pi
especially like for young um people like
Jen C whole 41 I think what they doing
is so so cool I love [__] like that like
I love that you know they just kids and
they're positive they ain't doing no
crazy stupid [__] they're so those are
some sweet kids they come on my show
twice in the last few months they're
they are so sweet I love everything
that's happening for them they like I
had them try black coffee on my show for
the first time in their life I want to
see that they told me during the
interview they're like yeah we don't we
ain't never had no coffee I'm
like you've never had coffee they like
16 like nah I'm like you never had black
coffee so I went to my boy went to the
store and he got he went to 7-Eleven and
we had them everyone tried black coffee
from 7-Eleven and they all spit it out
mhm I bet yeah no I mean listen black
coffee is an acquired taste I like black
coffee me too I like black cfee it's
right here there no sugar you know it's
good it goes straight to your like
sometimes just need like a yeah it's
also laxative hell yeah you drink that
black coffee you got to hit the [__]
real
quick for you you should not be drinking
black coffee before you go on stage
right have you ever had to use a
restroom during a show actually no but
you know what's so funny every time I be
so nervous before I go on stage I be
like oh I got to pee yeah and they
everybody gets annoyed but I'll be like
I got to pee I'll hold it it's okay and
then every time every time damn never
fails I don't know why something wrong
with me get when people get nervous they
piss yeah my dog does it both of my dogs
my dog gets excited he'll pee a little
bit when you come home after not seeing
your dog for a while does he get excited
and piss everywhere yeah or his not even
PE but his penis will come out yeah I be
like put it away I'm your mother both of
my dogs dicks come out when you see him
yeah it's kind of weird it is disgusting
I'll be like can you relax like is your
dog neutered nope is it a Frenchie no
he's actually a pitbull see him oh nice
yeah show me I'm show you I love dogs I
have a pit bull his name is Thor who's
babysitting Thor while you're my uh
sister okay my sister she is the best
Titi ever this is
Thor oh Thor is beautiful isn't he
that's a cute dog that's Thor and then
I'll show you storm I haven't gotten
storm yet she's still just a little baby
she's like 4 weeks old and it was
important to me that she stayed with her
mom the full eight weeks check you out
for people who don't know okay if a
breeder tries to sell you a dog before
it's 8 weeks old they're shitty breeders
yes they are because they're supposed to
be shoted up and with their mom exactly
yeah and this is Storm I'mma show you
her hold on she's just the cutest little
thing ever she is um um what do you call
it a um like a pull a beautiful dog
she's a beautiful dog and she's just so
freaking cute so storm and Thor are
going to be kicking it tough she's a
pocket bully is what she is a pocket
what a pocket bully oh yeah so she's
like a little mini bulldog